[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL SAXMAN: Hello, and welcome
to this week's episode
of Google Maps Developers
Live.
I'm Paul Saxman, and this week
I'm going to talk about
Mapping With Style, or
more commonly known
as Google Maps Styles.
And talk about ways that you
can actually take your Map,
your Google Map, and your
website, style it to make it
kind of fit your data, or your
website's look and feel.
I've taken actually a few of the
styles that I put together
recently for--
you might have seen in the last
couple of weeks-- for the
ship visualizations.
Kind of show you those and how
to put those together.
Talk a little bit about why
I picked certain styling
constraints.
And show you this tool that
I've been working on for
evaluating these styles--
and hopefully a tool that we
can make publicly available
before too long.
Before I get into that,
however, one quick
announcement is that the Google
Places API Developer
Challenge has two weeks
remaining for submissions.
So if you're working on an
application for the challenge,
now's your chance to-- or now's
the time to get in.
There's two weeks for
submission, I think it's the
last day of November.
And yeah, we've seen a lot of
great submissions so far, but
we're definitely looking forward
to seeing any more.
So please, submit away.
And so with that, let me get
into the visualizations a
little bit.
If we can take a look
at my screen here.
So if you've been tuning into
the show, or use Google Maps,
this will probably
look familiar, at
least the map itself.
This is a unstyled Google Map.
So it's basically just a basic
interface that you get with--
you can embed it in a website
with a few lines of code.
Stuff around the periphery
are little
controls that I've added.
I'll talk about these, and how I
added these in a little bit.
But one thing that I did here,
I got two little things in
this interface.
One is this little
styles pull up.
These are five of my
favorite styles.
And you can tell that I'm not
quite a designer, because none
of these styles have any
real color to them.
I'm kind of a monochrome
designer.
But I've actually played around
with a couple of these
with different color palates,
and I'll talk about how you
can swap out black
for other colors.
The other thing that I have in
this interface here is, I put
this-- this is a ACE Editor.
So as I switch these styles we
can actually look at the code
real time--
actually, the map style.
So I'm just taking whatever map
style and applying to the
map, and dropping it in this
little code box here.
And these little buttons
over on the top
left, these are for--
I'm just testing different
things in my visualization.
So this whole side I put
together in probably
about a days time.
And like I said, hopefully
we can--
if you guys think it looks
useful or interesting--
productize it.
But the other thing I did more
recently is, I put in this
little interface here, so we
can look for different--
this uses the Google Places
API AutoComplete, you just
search for a place, and
it will actually
take you right there.
So with that, let's take a look
at some of these styles.
And so the first style that I
put together, I don't know
what I'm calling any of these
styles necessarily.
But you get rid of
the style bar--
so this is what I call the,
well, I'm just calling it
pale, or the no-color style.
So basically what I've done
is I've built this style
particularly for urban
visualization.
So if you want to do something
like show a heat map for
density, let's say traffic
density or population density,
I think this is actually really
a nice map to use
because your data actually
really sits out on kind of the
desaturated map background.
And also, the important thing
about this is, specifically
for urban visualization, all the
other information such as
the roads, and the
neighborhoods, and place
names, they're all
still in the map.
So this actually has all the
same information as this map,
except it's desaturated and some
of the colors are kind of
tweaked a little bit.
So all the information is there,
it's just desaturated.
So you can do things like
render heat map.
One thing I did in this
tool is, I just put a
little heat map thing.
So I can click on the--
let's draw something.
Actually I'm kind
of way off now.
So we can actually see what
a heat map looks on this
visualization.
The heat map's not a
default heat map.
I've actually done things like
blown up the radius a little
bit so you can actually
see it.
Otherwise the points are a
little bit small on the map.
And that's also, if I hit this
a couple times, I have a few
different heat map styles
that I kind of like.
And actually this one, I call
this the kind of rainbow
pastel heat map.
I've just basically taken all
the primary colors, and kind
of bumped up the other color so
it fits a nice pastel, and
rank that from blue up to red.
This is another one.
So this is the heat map gradient
that I used for the
ship's visualization.
This is just kind of
a fierier hot.
And this is actually
one I kind of like.
It's kind of muted, but I
haven't gotten confirmation
that anybody else likes it.
But it's just a red
to beige gradient.
It's a little bit muted, so a
little less intense as the
other ones.
So if we go back to even the
default heat map, we toggle
between style.
Obviously since there's a lot of
color in heat map, you can
see that it really sticks out on
the desaturated background.
Another thing that's really
interesting about this one--
I'll move off centered
a little bit--
is that default map markers
actually stick out
quite a bit as well.
So you can see the red marker
with the kind of grey shadow
fits really well with the
desaturated background.
With the other red information
in the map less sticks out a
little less with the
standard map style.
The code for the-- let's
go back to the style--
this was actually relatively
straightforward to build.
What I did is actually just take
saturation for the entire
map down 100%.
So that's just getting
rid of all the color.
I actually made the water
a little darker.
When you desaturate everything,
things start to
blend in a little bit so.
So then you actually have to
start tweaking lightness to
actually build up contrast
between the different pieces
of information in your map.
So the water lightness I dropped
down about 30 points.
The water labels, I actually
brought those up a little bit.
None on this map, but you
can trust me they're--
make it a little more visible.
The roads, and the parks,
the points of interest--
so the roads I actually brought
up the lightness to
make them a little less visible,
because the roads are
actually in kind of a
white background.
Or the map, when you desaturate
it, has kind of a
whitish gray background.
So bringing up the lightness is
going to make them a little
less apparent.
Same thing with the parks,
I actually brought the
brightness up quite a bit.
So you can see maybe around
some of these
parks in the town.
The one thing I'd probably, if
I were going to actually use
this in production code
though, or this map in
production, I'd probably want to
actually tweak the road or
the park lightness
a little bit.
Because if we do zoom out,
especially where there's a lot
of roads, you can kind of see
it gets a little bit blurry.
Not super useful.
As you zoom in though, I think
it does a really nice job of
showing the various roads.
And that's actually another
trick you can actually do with
these visualizations,
with these maps.
If you pick a particular style,
and you like it at a
certain level, and the other
levels they don't look as
good, what you can do is you can
actually constrain the min
and max view of the map.
So you can say that you don't
want the map to zoom out into
one of the zoom levels, it
doesn't look really good.
And like I said, this style
was designed for urban
visualizations, or urban maps.
So I might just want to
constrain it to a lower zoom
level, and not let users zoom
all the way out to the
regional level.
The last thing that I put in
here-- actually I turned the
terrain off.
And so you've been following--
we added terrain to the default
maps not too long ago.
And let's see if we get a
good picture of that.
Heat map's a little
bit distracting.
I'm going to turn that guy
off, and the marker.
And so terrain, if we go back
to the default style--
not too much around Paris.
But if we--
let's just go back to San
Francisco, because I know
there's a lot of terrain
around San Francisco.
So yeah, the terrain up here in
the Golden Gate Recreation
Area, the Muir Woods area--
so with this first style
that I had actually,
we turn that off.
On to the next style.
So let's bring our pull up
here, and go to this one.
So this one actually, the
purpose for this one was to
show roads and transit a
little more prominent.
Just looking at the map, you
can see I've desaturated--
or actually brought the
lightness up on the
background, or the base of the
map, and actually brought the
roads a little bit forward, and
also obviously got rid of
all the labels.
So you see with the-- this
is the default style.
When we switch over to this
new style, roads actually
really stick out quite
a bit more.
And the reason I did this is
actually I wanted to look at
transit information.
So here I have the transit
layer on top of the map.
This one actually looks really
good in Paris as well, so go
back to Paris.
Also Japan looks great,
because they
have really nice transit.
But you can see the transit
lines stick out really nicely.
So if you're building a
visualization around roads or
transit, a simple
thing to do--
just, if we go to this--
this is a pretty short style.
So I've simplified everything
in the map.
I mean, that does
things like--
simplify generally gets rid of
the strokes around a lot of
the features on the map.
I turned all the labels off, so
that's getting rid of all
the text on the map.
The landscape geometry, I
brought up the lightness.
And that's actually making it
a little less apparent, or
faded-looking.
I guess I could also use
saturation as another way I
could approach that.
The terrain, I turned the
terrain off like I did with
the other map.
Road geometry, so that's
actually the roads themselves,
I actually made sure those
were on, and not in a
simplified mode, and then
brought their lightness up.
A couple other things--
oh, local roads.
So you see, if I zoom in here
and switch back to here, you
can see the local roads that
are in white on the default
map, those are all gone.
Because for this visualization,
if we're just
looking at transit, or inner
city transit, or pan-city
transit, the local roads don't
really matter as much.
And park geometry, again I
brought the lightness up to
make it a little
less apparent.
Because I think by default,
the parks are a little bit
dark for doing visualizations.
So on to number three.
So these last three, I just kind
of had fun with styling
with these.
Actually let's turn
transit off.
And let's skip the code--
shrink this guy.
So this one, when you're looking
at it, just looks like
a lot of text and rivers,
or text and lines.
So basically the land geometry
is black, and
the rivers are white.
So I've actually inversed
the contrast here.
And the text I actually left
in, just for demonstration.
But in general, this map, I like
to view it without text.
The interesting thing about
this, because I picked this
inverse contrast between the
water and the land, is this
one is actually really good
for looking at things like
lakes, or inland bodies
of water.
So when you look at this map
here, so this is in the
Ukraine, you can actually see
a lot of these inland lakes.
Whereas if we hit the style
button and go back to default
style, you don't necessarily
see them very much.
And that's primarily because
there's not as much contrast
between the default color for
the land geometry and the
water, as you get with
the style on.
Zoom out.
You can actually
see some really
interesting things with this.
I've discovered things like,
well, obviously like Canada
has actually quite
a few lakes.
You can see these interesting
kind of circular feature here,
circular lake in--
I believe that's Quebec.
So you really get a sense of the
presence of inland water
using this really
stark contrast,
inverted stark contrast.
So this map is really about
understanding local water bodies.
I put in the labels, just to
give the user a sense of where
they're at on the map.
Another thing that I--
just kind of browsing around
this map-- is you can really
see these--
I think a lot of these
are irrigation
channels, or aqueducts.
So kind of interesting to see
these in the map as well.
Again, if we go back to the
standard styling, you really
don't quite a sense of how
many, or how much of the
inland water there is.
And not a great map I
think, this black
background for heat maps.
Well, we'll try that
out a little bit.
But in some cases, like where
we're talking about land
masses, it doesn't make a lot
of sense for heat maps.
This is actually the heat map
I used for the ship voyage.
So my point here--
well, we can go back
real quick.
Take a quick look at the
code for this one.
Pretty simple.
So what I talked about in
previous shows is for doing
visualizations, it usually helps
to turn everything off,
and then selectively
add stuff back in.
Which I did with this map, and
actually the next few ones.
So actually this first directive
here is turning
everything off in the map.
So we don't have any features.
And if you do that,
you actually get--
your map is transparent, which
is a really interesting trick
that I will take advantage
of in a little bit.
So water, making it this
grayish color.
Landscape, making it black.
The roads-- actually I turned
the roads back on and made
them black so that you can
actually see the--
whoops, I have some heat
map points in here.
The heat map was
on, that's why.
So you can actually see
the bridge here.
This is the Golden
Gate Bridge.
If I did not turn the roads back
on, you'd just see the
land masses and the water,
without the roads overlaid or
the bridges overlaid.
Which is actually kind of a
decent effect, but looking at
this map gave me a little
more sense of location.
And just basically tweaking the
properties for the labels
on the water and on the land.
I think at one point I had just
used the inverse lightness.
You can use that to-- actually,
if it's a white fill
with a black stroke for
the text, it'll
actually invert that.
I didn't use it in here, just
because I guess I didn't
really like the colors that
the inverse lightness is.
A little easier, a little
nicer presentation, to
actually just set the
colors myself.
Moving on, this was the
ship visualization.
So my goal with this was I
wanted to plot a lot of data,
actually a whole lot of
data, in the water.
And the land masses are actually
just about showing
that, well, the ship went from
point A to point B-- from the
city to the city.
But the really important
information was actually in
the water, and that was the
voyages of the ships.
So here I actually picked black
for the background, for
the water, which let me use some
really sharp colors, or
bright colors, or pastel
colors for the voyage.
And unfortunately with this tool
that I put together, I
didn't make any way
to add polylines.
But we can turn the
heat map back on.
Let's get to this
more pastel one.
But you can see, as we add
these points to the black
background here, it actually
pops out really nicely.
Primarily because there's not
a lot of text here that it's
overlaying.
If we go back over here, over
to the land, the heat map
points that I plotted earlier
are a little bit more washed
out on the slightly more
gray background.
You could definitely tweak
this a little bit.
And I've definitely seen some
really nice visualizations
that did like white water with
some kind of pastel, or even
maybe some pastel polylines,
which looks really nice.
But if you want to really turn
up the amount of contrast,
this is a good way
to go about it.
I think we covered the code
for this little while ago.
I think it's a lot like the
other map, where like I said
before, I turn off the
visibility on everything.
And then selectively turn on
things like the water, the
text, et cetera, et cetera.
This one, actually, I purposely
turned on the labels
for the country and
localities.
This is because I wanted to
show what cities the ships
were coming from and going to.
So I had a polyline going, for
example, from London across to
New York for example.
And you can actually see what
cities the ships were coming
from and going to.
If I didn't turn these labels
back on, because previously in
the style I actually turned
visibility off for everything,
you wouldn't be able to
see these labels.
And so that's about
it for that one.
Actually really tweaking the--
let me see what I'm
doing here.
Oh, this is actually just
setting up the countries, or
the land masses, which
fills in nicely.
So the very last one, this
is not necessarily a
visualization that
I'd want to use.
And actually you can see
at this level it
doesn't really do much.
I just want to turn
the heat map off.
So this style is something
I put together recently.
I think this is a
lot of fun for--
actually let me find some
place that has roads.
Paris is always a good one.
So for actually just looking at
the density of roads in a
particular area, or
a particular city.
What I did is I basically turned
everything off of the
map, made it black.
And then took the roads and just
made them white, a nice
stark color.
I played around with inverse.
I mean, it looked actually
really nicely to do a white
background with black lines,
or even like a
dark blue or red lines.
But you get the most contrast,
obviously, with
the black to white.
The really nice thing
about this--
hopefully it comes through on
YouTube-- is that we can
actually see the primary.
The freeways or the highways,
and also the secondary roads
being mapped in here in kind of
a different contrast level.
That's just how they're mapped
by default, or how they're
plotted by default.
I don't know if we have
that level of
detail for all countries.
Like, for example,
I was in Tokyo.
I'm going to go Edogawa,
Tokyo, Japan.
You see here at this level, we
don't see the secondary roads.
They actually fill in
in the same color.
Zoom in here, the secondary
roads actually fill in at the
same kind of contrast level
as the other roads.
You can tweak that
using the style.
But what we saw with Paris,
on the other hand,
looks really nice.
So I'm actually thinking about
doing like a weekly posting
one of these maps up on the
Google Maps Developers Google+
channel, so you can even figure
out where this is.
And I put a nice little
flag in here.
I can actually convert these
styled maps into static maps.
So this is actually pretty much
just a snapshot of where
the map is positioned right
now, as a JPEG file.
Or I think it's PNG file.
But yeah, so like I said, that's
pretty much it for this
tool, pretty much it
for the styles.
I have a few more styles that
I've been working on for other
visualization.
But I'll spare you guys those
for the time being, until I
can actually tweak them
a little bit more.
The other thing I was going
to do real quick is,
I was really inspired.
We were down at Sydney last
week, and we went to an
observatory that was dedicated
to us celestial
navigation in Sydney.
And they had some really nice
historical maps, ship log or
ship maps, very similar to what
we were trying to show
with the Google Maps API with
the ship visualization.
Although these maps obvious
were quite a bit simpler.
They just had outlines for
countries, labels for the
countries, and then the voyage
was actually marked in a
different color, like
a nice red color.
Obviously on kind of aged paper,
because these were
actually real historic maps.
So I wanted to actually see if
I could reproduce that in the
Google Maps API.
And it surprisingly wasn't too
hard, with a few caveats.
I can't actually share the code
for this one right yet,
because I want to actually tweak
it a little bit more and
make it a little more usable.
But the idea behind this is,
and this is actually using
Styled Maps, plus a few other
Google Maps techniques.
The first thing I did is
actually I turned visibility
off for everything
on this map.
And like I mentioned before,
that actually makes the map
background transparent.
So doing that, you get a
transparent background.
And then I can just use a
tile-able image for the
background of the map canvas.
Then what I did is I actually
just turned on the labels for
the countries.
And actually I did the
countries and--
let's zoom in a little bit--
countries and localities.
So we have cities as well, and
you can see these pop in at a
particular zoom level.
Then I was left with a little
bit of a problem, because if
we turn on the geometry for
administrative, like the
countries, it only shows the
boundaries between countries.
It doesn't show the
boundaries around
the edge of the country.
So the next trick I did was
actually find a KML file that
actually had the full
country boundaries.
And you can see, they're
not super detailed.
Just for performance reasons,
you can see they're a little
bit, how do we say,
coarse-grained around the borders.
But I think it does a pretty
good job, especially when
you're at a higher zoom level.
My next step with this map would
be to actually plot a
voyage in here to see what it
looks like in this archaic
map, or historical map format.
This one I hope to share
out at some point.
I just want to make sure I get
all the attribution right for
the polylines, or for the KML,
and also for this kind of
parchment-style background
that I used.
But yeah, stay tuned, and we'll
hopefully get that out
sometime this week.
And with that, I think
that's everything.
Do I have any other bags?
LEWIS: We do have some
questions, Paul.
PAUL SAXMAN: Oh, we have
some questions.
Ok, we have the man behind
the curtain.
LEWIS: So Andre had a
couple questions.
And he wanted to know if there's
any examples that you
have using Closure or
Closure Script.
PAUL SAXMAN: --for using
Google Maps API.
That's a really--
so in my code I am
using closures,
like JavaScript closure.
Let me see if I can actually
bring up some of the--
actually probably
not this code.
So I'm not using clojure.
So I'm just using JavaScript
closure, making sure that all
my event handlers are attached
to the appropriate object at
creation time.
We can definitely see if we can
bring up some examples for
that, because I think it's a
common question that we get.
LEWIS: And you said you weren't
releasing everything,
but is there a chance
that they could
download your examples?
Like, where can you
point people?
PAUL SAXMAN: Yes.
So I haven't publicized
it yet, but the ship
visualizations that we put
together last week, I just put
them online actually
very recently.
And I'll follow up with that
today or tomorrow.
So ship visualizations
will be out there.
The paper map, like I said, I
have to get it vetted before I
can launch it.
Just to make sure that I get the
attribution right for the
other content that
I pulled in.
And this tool that I put
together, this tool here, if
there's interest in it, then
we can probably look at
productizing it.
This was something that, like
I said, I put together in
about a day just to kind of
help me tweak my styles.
But it might make a nice tool,
especially if developers could
load their own styles.
So either way, we can put this
code someplace for you to
download, or make it like a
tool that you can use for
doing your own map styling.
So stay tuned on the code.
Today or tomorrow we can
see the ship data.
And then maybe early next week
some of this data that we
presented today.
And producer Lewis says we're
OK on the questions.
So with that, next week we're
maybe going to do another data
visualization show, but
not 100% sure yet.
But we'll definitely get that
posted as soon as we know.
And if you guys have any other
questions, or any other ideas
for shows, please share.
We want to make sure
that we're getting
information to you guys.
I think this closure idea,
actually clojure, is
maybe a good idea.
AngularJS is another
big one that people
like to see as well.
So stay tuned, we'll definitely
consider those.
And any other ideas, and any
other comments or questions,
please let us know.
With that, have a
great weekend.
And see you guys next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]